[Music]
Ryan Schubert fellow fan of video games
also a fan of science fiction and movies
we got to play something which kind of
crosses all those things and things we
love so much and do much alien isolation
oh haha so we got to play as survivor
mode which is this I guess it's kind of
like their their DLC plan they're gonna
have one mission the mission we played
right in the game and then they're gonna
sell additional missions basically
survivor mode is you have an objective
to do you have a ticking clock on a
bunch of side objectives there's one
alien between you and your objective go
go
yeah and I'm died over and over okay
you're not expected to be able to get
through it on your first try they did
tell us that they sort of expected
people to be playing this with the
experience of having gone through the
campaign so your which we happen we did
not but the idea is that you are more or
less a veteran player at the point that
you're trying these challenges and you
have to use your wits your experience as
well as just about anything you can find
in the environment that can help you
yeah so they start you off in this kind
of a small room there's a bunch of like
different objects you can then craft
into stuff like noisemakers Molotov
cocktails and they also start you with a
flamethrower but it's only good for like
one blast rice you get one blast of the
flamethrower you get one use out of the
Molotov you get one use out of the
noisemaker you know you really have to
use those things intelligently or
creatively to get through the whole
mission and but mostly what you're
essentially doing is like breaking
line-of-sight like you'reyou're you're
like hiding behind stuff crawling
underneath tables yes basically looking
to see where this massive awful-looking
like it's like itself creepy looking
it's just like like a witch standing out
in field so if the alien is more scary
than ever in this game and I and it's
and part of that is that they're got the
environment almost photographically
identical to the movie yeah it just it
feels like you're inside of alien and
the thing that makes that just extra
terrifying is that this isn't your
normal AI this one is smarter its
cunning it is more observant yeah that
you know as they explained to us if
you're underneath the table that it's
standing right next to it can't see you
but if it's ten feet away from that
table and you're underneath it it sees
you under the table again it's attracted
to fire and sound and so those crafted
tools in the flamethrower basically the
only line of defense you have there's no
offense you can't kill the alien so
you're forever in peril in this
challenge mode you want to finish as
quickly as possible so you're going to
take a lot more risk
that was the worst it was like because
of the unpredictability because the area
might be going left or right because
like sometimes you can just there might
be a window where you can just maybe go
through fast and try and like it might
be there I kept doing it like I couldn't
see it and the motion tracker is telling
me that it's it's somewhere maybe above
me it doesn't do Heights you know oh man
I think I can go now
if you run it'll hear you hears you go
past the door opens it'll hear you but
if you're like in this little car door
you're like if I can just get there now
and you kind of just start you're like
you're not really sure it might be
behind you you don't read and then
suddenly like this bike you stop in
anyway it's just like oh this game is
the worst and then back to the start and
I love the good fun it does still it has
that feeling of those survival horror
games where you almost don't want to
open the door in front of one of my
favorite parts was that to complete the
mission the goal was to get to an
elevator yeah and to complete the
mission you had to find a generator that
would start up the elevator and the when
you the first time you find that
generator and realize that to start the
generator you have to make a lot of
noise
oh no no no no no no no oh [ __ ] ah it's
a fantastic and hopefully with each of
the releases that they do and they've
said that they're not all going to just
be a time trial yeah or they might be
timed but they're not all going to be
get to an objective some of it is just
survived for a certain amount of time or
whatever but that these elements in the
game that aren't just about the
objective but the sort of fear of going
forward which i think is important to
like survival horror yeah at one stage
you knocked over a chair by accident
remember nothing over the chair no hide
under the desk can you crazy person and
then that yelling comes around like kick
the chair agent
it looks staying in the corner oh no I
guess it's seeing like is that scary
like like a couple of hours into the
game II right that's it because like you
started like you hear the noise of the
alien going into the dock and you hear
you recognize the noise of the moving
back down right doctor so it becomes you
know inherently more mechanical just by
interacting with it long enough and I
never really felt like I was in control
of like I knew what the yelling would do
like a one-stage I went into one of
those ventilation tunnels yeah
and like I peeked my head to the end
that it opened and the alien was like
down the hall I was I don't know I can't
I better walk back through the tunnel
again to the close again
and then I was on the sensor and I
thought it had gone the other way and I
poked my head out and then it came from
behind the end of the tunnel every time
like it's just the camera takes over and
it turns you ran and screaming at you
like
it'll be interesting to see whether just
the mechanics of the game are still so
good that you want to play them even
though you're not as scared yeah maybe
that's why they have all those
additional objectives and to make us
maybe it's less about the fear that or
more just about the difficulty because
there were ones like there was one to
like I think was disabled or closed down
and a stairwell or a low down and the
more you do of those the more they shape
on your sort of leaderboards right
there's a world I'd like I think you
went for one or two of them I was just
trying to get to get metal let's try to
just thought I'd blame them just before
alien isolation is coming out Xbox 360
Xbox one ps3 ps4 and PC wow it's on
everything over seven so we want up that
much longer to get the bejesus scared
out of us all over I can't wait
oh [ __ ] of God God nope nope
was he human
oh-oh-oh-oh dozen rounds
Oh God